[Music]
at the 2020 elections loom the education
abates will be shaped by opinions that
get less attention than they deserve
first while most Americans give their
own community schools in Arabi just a
quarter give the nation schools those
grades
that's why voters tune out candidates
who suggest their local schools are
failing even while accepting that
schools somewhere else may need stronger
medicine second three-quarters of
Americans support teacher pay increases
but support drop substantially after
respondents are told what the average
teacher actually earns teacher pay
increases have real appeal but teachers
should take care not to overstate their
case
third Americans regardless of race
support stricter school discipline by
nearly a 10 to 1 margin parents will be
skeptical of proposals thought to weaken
school discipline candidates should take
care to listen to what voters think and
not just what advocates might have them
believe do you think teachers deserve a
raise let us know in our poll also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe more research
and videos from AEI